all right everybody welcome to another
business Q&A while we play League of
Legends helping answer some questions
for entrepreneurs we missed yesterday I
was dealing with I had a meeting so I
had to deal with that and today we've
had some fire alarm issues so we'll see
if that continues or not hopefully not
but I am back with my usual co-host
Rishi Cup TV welcome aboard Thank You
Evan so appreciative to be here today
cup of love I love it okay ready i also
have j rise in the house he's going to
be i think setting up again he wants to
try something new he's trying to
experiment with a new champion so
that'll be that'll be interesting to see
halloween right oh the fire alarm is
back so they are testing we'll see we'll
see how ha ha at last they are testing
fire alarm Jill's at my place alex has
been gracious enough to come in and meet
mute it when it comes in what is in the
cup today we she's a cup of love uh yeah
it's always a couple of Evan and yeah
and that's it that's my custody of love
I love it well I've got my cup of
vitaminwater that alex says inspires me
daily so I'm excited to drink that damn
all right we got some people in the live
chat Jen so much she wants to know what
that food channel is from the gratitude
journal so you'll have to you have to
you have to share that Rishi people are
judging want to know put oh you already
did you put it in the chat okay awesome
um yeah well let's get to some questions
so do we have up first what we went for
a game thing kills it up first sir ever
everybody wants to know if you're
feeling okay we're hearing in your voice
a little bit of sickness maybe I'm okay
I had
I had a rough night two nights ago not
last night two nights ago and I usually
go through my morning of having lots of
liquids that I am just starting so i
gotta i gotta down my vitamin water that
inspires me daily nice well we want we
want to make sure you're doing okay so i
love it feeling the love guys okay so
are you ready for the first question yes
let's do it right first question comes
from Agnes and Agnes is asking how do
you manage a team successfully how do
you keep them motivated he has a team
that's constantly losing his focus on
their work and so yeah I just wanted to
kind of get some I guess leadership team
feedback sorta for an unfocused team um
yeah well first of all to say you know I
know I'm not leading on any kind of
level as um in but I have held
leadership positions and I know that
even when you're doing a good job it can
be incredibly difficult so anyone who
just steps out in and as being an
entrepreneur and once and you're at the
place where you have a team you know you
should definitely take some time just in
terms of our gratitude stream that we
just came out of you know take some time
to be grateful for what you're doing
well and try to make sure you're paying
attention to the things that you are
doing well because I think you can get
caught up in what you're not doing well
aside from that though I know that kind
of part of the harder truth to all of
this is that your team is always a
reflection of you so you know sometimes
we don't like what it is that we see in
our team but it really does come down to
a reflection of us in some way so the
more
where you can become about your
leadership style and the maybe some of
your weaknesses you know the better us
about motivating your team I think
motivation comes I mean just take Evan
for example like and we're all excited
to hang out with Evan because Evans a
passionate guy and he's on fire and he
has huge vision and and so that's
inspiring and and also I noticed to Evan
in your leadership you're very clear on
your values like believe so I think the
more clear you're on your values and and
what it is that you're passionate about
the mortally for easier for people to be
motivated to work for you there's so
many aspects to to this but I guess you
know I think without going into too many
details again coming back to the
self-awareness can you ask your team for
feedback even you know what are some
areas that they might feel more
motivated by you or what causes them to
feel like they're losing their focus I
think getting feedback is really
important when you're a leader from your
team all right that's all I got for now
look I want to see if i can grab alex i
want i'm curious to hear his song i like
this question I don't know hey Alice
question okay it's kevin sorry so uh you
got to either come and tight on this one
it says there you go this Alex hey guys
he helps me run Toronto dance salsa uh
tds we have how many people on the team
from instructors or everyone well if you
look at the instructors in assistance
and like people at the front like 1000
people at the front and instructors yeah
about 10 to 12 and then helpers we have
52 52 hours I think 40 in the grinding
ok see ya to do go we've got this is a
team that that Alex and I have to manage
the question really me know if I if I
gotta run the way no but the question is
about the guy there's a business he's
having a hard time keeping this team
focused and motivated so the question is
how do I keep my team focused and
motivated is that right Rishi they get
all right yeah exactly him and yep
mm-hmm so how do we keep our team
focused and motivated ah I think two
things aren't born one I think the team
needs to know what your big picture is
for the business and how you try to make
an impact um so I are for people it's
easier for people to stand behind
something that's bigger than them that
has a bigger impact and that they can be
part of so you know I would never go to
any of the volunteers to help us big
let's make more money kind of thing
right I'd be like I want to make
people's lives better and I think you
can do it too so one aspect is for your
team to know what your vision is and how
they can help and that's the second part
of it our sorry the second part of it is
understanding why they're there and
trying to make it personalized for them
the experience right so you know people
work for money people work for this
people work for that but deep down they
all look for something internal for me
it was I wanted to find a place where I
belong and so I found out at TDs and
some helpers they wanted to you know get
past certain fears and certain and this
and that so you just speak to each of
your
teammates right employees however you
refer to them and try to understand them
why they're there and you know what
they're trying to get out of life it not
only builds a better relationship
between you you and your co-workers or
your teammates but it also makes me feel
fulfilled and to be more involved in
your vision I don't know that's a lot I
like it I've done that's good yes ma'am
I would oh thank you okay back to work
Alex come on um I GI go a lot of what
Alex said I love it I agree with angry
with it all um what would I add to that
he stole a lot of what i would say i
guess you hang around too much um uh i
would say a big part of it is also
recruitment making sure you get the
right people i'm trying to try to fix
the wrong people the biggest part of
building a team is getting the right
people on the bus first so a great way
to do that to alex is pouring and
reaches point about knowing what you
stand for that can attract people people
know why you're doing something then
it'll attract people who love the
mission that you're on if you have an
unclear mission and you just hiring a
web developer then it's just going to be
around okay how much money can I make
and once you get into working together
you may find you have a lot of values
that don't work well with each other so
we're making sure that you bring the
right people on is extremely important
what I would then add is everybody needs
to be treated differently and that's
that's a one of the biggest challenges
of leadership is you you want to treat
everybody like you would want to be
treated and and yes is like the golden
rule and you wanna you
on a high level you want to be you want
to be good to people like you would want
them to be good to you but when you get
into the execution of it some people
might need a lot of praise some people
need a lot of recognition some people
need a lot of opportunities some people
need a lot of expression and create a
freedom you know some people some people
want to work inside a block so like I
need rules give me rules to operate some
people hate a box and they need creative
freedom and expression some people have
low self confidence and they need more
of that from you to say that you're that
they're doing a good job and some people
like don't give me compliments tell me
tell me what I need to fix and so the
default for most people is this is how
you know I was treated where this is how
you know my parents treated me here this
is how I like to be treated and assuming
that that's the default for everybody
and it's not and for most teams for most
entrepreneurs for most most first hires
don't work out if you look at companies
and how many who their first high was
there very rarely still with the company
and its it's the entrepreneurs fault
like you hired the wrong person you had
no idea how to manage somebody and you
didn't know how to treat them and so
that's not a you know recipe for success
and hopefully somewhere along the line
to figure you figure some of that stuff
out so I definitely feel for you having
this team but that's not motivated you
know do they like the work that they're
doing are they feeling growth
opportunities are they feeling listen to
do they feel important do they feel like
the work they're doing this challenge in
them do they feel attached to the
mission is there a mission although
those things are super important to
think about as you build a team and and
you know my gratitude journal just
before this in the live stream the first
thing I was good before was my team so
this is a timely question because you
can't do it alone and what happens to a
lot of entrepreneurs is they start off
alone and they said okay i need help and
they go in to hire somebody and then
that person doesn't work out and you
spend so much time training that person
and then it doesn't work out you get so
frustrated like okay you know forget
this I'm not building a team I'm just
gonna I'm just going to go back to do
everything myself because I know that I
can at least get it done and that's not
the right attitude because you need to
be able to if you want to go out a
couple something big you can't do it all
by yourself so I feel yet stay strong
yeah and I love what you guys talked
about on Thursday you and even Kelly CEO
stage I mean you know you can you can be
very serious about what you do but it's
got to still have heart and what you
guys were talking about how you know the
most productive businesses belongs to
recruit the best are the ones who have
heart you know and I think sometimes
people just forget to also pursue
meaningful work not just you know
serious boring you know so I think
people want to work for a place that's
fun and well I know I want to work for
places fun but maybe not fun is what
everybody wants but at least meaningful
yes you know and you guys touched on
that I like that a lot yeah intense age
is in a boring in the street like I know
I'm accounting it's like the most boring
thing of all time for those people now I
get that some people love numbers and in
some people you know they're big
accounting faith is great but it's also
a big company you've got like 15,000
employees or something there so you're
going to have human resources people and
marketing people and all kinds of non
accountants why would they ever pick the
work go work in an accounting software
company it sounds like the most boring
thing in the world but because the
mission isn't about accounting is about
helping entrepreneurs do big things to
change the world so it's a lot easier to
get on board with that mission then just
accounting so is that that's a great
example I love it it's easy to want to
be involved in in a you know video game
company or some new you know technology
or you know biotech startup or something
fun and innovative it's hard when it
accounting software you can apply it to
any industry for doing something
meaningful so yeah I love it thanks for
sharing that example oh thank you for
your collaboration on Thursdays with SEO
or with Stephen Kelly be you all right
um next question comes from and we
started the game by the way yes sorry we
are in game uh I am Timo jungle gr eyes
is trying a new experiment of Pantheon
top which I think he's been practicing
that we've never done it we've never
done it together yeah narrow so this
should be fun to see what happens
alrighty angles so um next question
comes from Ian and Anne says I love
music where do I start sounds like an as
a singer songwriter producer or actually
I think he doesn't really quite know but
you just love music any wants to kind of
get some guidance on where to start so
yeah I think that's kind of the first
thing that you got to start us to
society I mean you love music what about
the music do you specifically love do
you want to do you want to be on stage
do you want to be behind the scenes do
you want to be writing songs for other
singers do you want to be producing I
think that you just have to be in touch
with what it is that you want and
yeah if you don't know look at your
gifts look at your talents and skills
and who are people that you really
admire that you would aspire to to be
but once you figure that out you just
start you know I mean if you've never
played music before you just got to
start and you know you just gotta
practice and practice you grow and grow
I would also just add that as you are
learning your craft whatever you decide
to pursue that i would say value the
business side of music just as much as
you value the learning sky because many
a musicians have exceedingly amazing
talent but you'll never hear from them
or know about them because of what they
don't know about the business side so i
would i would also make sure that you
respect the business of music as well i
love it we have a series a new series on
the channel called making it and the
first one that we did was making it as a
musician and so i highly recommend you
checking that out there's a advice from
10 different people who are famous
musicians about how to make it in the
music industry and pretty much guarantee
you there's something in there for you
the new series that we're putting on the
word testing and starting to bring it to
other fields besides musicians next I
think we're doing acting next laughs but
anyway it's a new series I'm pretty
pumped up about it but we'll see we'll
see not all the new series stick so
we'll see what happens but i definitely
recommend check that out you're
fortunate that that was the first one
that we put together I think for being a
musician you need to you need to start
getting really good at your craft you
need to practice you need to get on you
need to get as many opportunities as you
can to get on stage in win over an
audience you need to start a YouTube
channel I don't know Rishi's users all
over the youtube channel advice
but he hecho let your music spread you
know it's never been easier to get a
message out there Oh Jerry I just got a
double kill good job pay ok Jayron is we
go nice this team is doing well um it's
never been easier to get exposure to
make it to get people listening to to
your your songs but you need to do the
work to get good the practice you need
to start one over some fans figuring out
what your style is maybe you don't know
maybe you still need to learn maybe you
still need to get better at singing get
better at the guitar get better at the
keyboard or whatever you know your
instrument is but that's going to be the
key for anybody who's trying to make it
and build build up a fanbase you start
and you just keep on keep on going keep
on improving just like somebody wants to
start a YouTube channel where do I start
well you start you get a camera and you
just start and make your first video and
expected the sock and then start another
one and every every time along the way
your goal is to win a couple fans so you
know with every every new song that you
you create and every new album you know
you put out or every new video that you
launch or every new concert that you go
out and sing you know you're not filling
stadiums you might just be at some bar
you're the local band or are you playing
on a street festival or something you're
your goal is to win over a couple of new
fans just like this like this live chat
here this stream that we're doing when
we started there was zero activity in
the in the chat mm-hmm zero right nobody
was paying attention I didn't heavily
promoted right I wasn't I could have I
could have built it up and said hey
everybody my newsletter let's go check
out this new thing that we started it
wasn't heavily promoted on my side I
wanted to just start an experiment and
we've been building up audience numbers
right they come back and they want to
check it out and see what the next thing
is um
mm-hmm so I think it's uh I'm under
attack here I think it's super important
and now we've got we've got a live
stream i haven't seen what's happening
in the chat but I see it kind of filling
up Jen and rishi and Optus aureus and
demas then the key thing is that people
come back and people coming back maybe
not every single episode but they're
coming back and that's how you start to
build your audience and a fan base so
are you good enough yet to be able to
have people listen to your music and
have them come back and if you're not
then you can practicing until you get
there anyway i think i'll just add one
little thing but this is just beyond
even music on I you know you think that
so much of this has to do with your
talent and abilities and it obviously is
a level of truth to that but I love a
quote that Julia Cameron says that often
it's not talent but audacity that brings
the artist to center stage and so I mean
so many people have been successful in
music or any other industry now because
they were the most talented but just
because they had the audacity to just to
just start and put themselves out there
and like you said evan has momentum keep
plugging away at it and keep doing it
and they found success so I love it
that's a good quote
love Julia all right next question oh
you've got to question the live chat
from optus source and she asked I was
going to ask a doctor that was a partner
of the founder of my business to be my
mentor I was very close to him as well
he is very high up in the community how
do I approach him so dr. partner and
founder of a business wanted to ask
about mentorship and how do I approach
him so this is just I think a question
that's relevant to anyone who is looking
for mentorship and we have talked about
that a lot on on different streams my
stance I think on mentorship always is
like to start by creating or by
providing value to that that person you
know sometimes people approach
relationship with what can I get from
this relationship and I know that's
probably that may not be optus source
who's that may not be her approach but a
lot of people are pursuing mentoring
relationships with just how can I get
instead of starting with what can I give
and so finding out what the potential
mentor may need a service you could
provide how you can volunteer make their
lives easier and a great benefit that
usually happens in return is that you
can learn from them in the process so
that's my kind of quick feedback about
mentoring it's add value to them and
that usually creates opportunity awesome
um here's the interesting thing about
mentorship everybody wants to the desert
is a lot of value in giving back good
people people like to get back people
like to feel appreciated people like to
feel like they can mentor and coach and
train the next generation
the challenge with it is that most
people are either not ready for the
feedback or they just don't work hard
enough to actually take the advice and
that sucks as a mentor you know even
thinking about these how many people who
are listening and asking questions how
many people actually take action on the
advice that we give hopefully it's a
good amount but the sad truth is it may
not be that much the hope though is that
by by sharing it other people have the
same problem same questions do realize
that you know they want to make a change
and they get inspired and moved by it I
can't tell you how many people and I use
this example before I think it was on
the live stream maybe not it was a video
you know I went to a vet where I was
talking about mentorship and people came
up to me afterwards and say hey can you
be my mentor what you never want to do
which we've talked about before as well
because mentorship applies in a
relationship it it's like walking up to
somebody and say will you marry me you
know will leave you my business partner
like that's not gonna happen wassup so
how it works so like you'd be creeped
out if somebody said will you marry me
so that's you know just keep that in
mind but most people don't follow up
most people don't do the work good and
that sucks like that as a mentor makes
me feel like I've wasted my time and
time is the most important most precious
thing that we have so don't make me feel
like I wasted my time mm-hmm so that's
the and the frustrating part is you know
you may be the person who won't waste
your time you will follow up you will do
the work you really appreciate it but
you're lumped in with everybody else
just like the business plan for a
venture capitalist you're loved in with
everybody else and so it's up to you to
stand out it's up to you to
be the one person that I can see that
you know what I think this person is
actually going to follow through visit
if I get that impression then I'm happy
to meet with you and learn about what
your problems are how I can contribute
so that's that's that's your first step
then in terms of reaching out if you
already have some kind of personal
connection if he knows your name that
already puts you ahead of most people
your next step is just to ask our coffee
don't go in and mass will you be my
mentor because again replies too big of
a relationship but go in and say I would
I you know I really appreciate your
wisdom and I was running if I could
quickly pick your brain for 20 minutes
over a cup of coffee or lunch or
whatever you know this guy likes to do
and doing that I would come in with a
clear goal like what's the one question
that you want this guy to answer that
could help you that could make the
difference in your life in your business
what's the one thing that you would just
love to get an answer to and focus in on
that and anything else you get on top of
it is bonus and great he'll see your
energy your enthusiasm that's awesome
but then the next step if you really
want to get a mentorship relationship
going is you have to go out and do work
so whatever you told you to do you say
you're going to do it actually go do it
don't come back to him again until
you've done it because the last thing
that I mentor wants to see is having to
solve the same problem again right you
asked me this question I gave you an
answer I told you what to do you didn't
go out and do it so why are you back
again Yeah right what why do you can I
ask question cuz why does that happen to
me where I tell someone they don't do it
but they want to keep coming back for
more like what battle about people just
want the emotional support people have
an environment that sucks people are
willing to push themself hard enough you
know like the people have a
why do people stay in in you know
abusive relationships like peoples
environment just socks you might be the
one positive thing the one positive
conversation that they've had and they
love it and then they go back to their
regular life where people aren't
supporting them and then you know the
next I mean you I'm sure you've
experienced it where you have an idea
you're all motivate and confident and
then the next day you wake up and it's
it's gone and you like you don't have
the courage anymore and you write you
you doubt yourself and say ahh I can't
do that who who was I to have that crazy
goal and so that's what happens like you
meet somebody who's who's done a lot
more than you and they're on a higher
trajectory and a greater path and they
think it a different way and they have
less limiting mindsets and beliefs and
so you get to hang around them a little
bit and a little bit of that rubs off on
you and you get a little bit more of
that audacity and then you fall back you
look at the rest of your life and you
wake up the next day you fall back into
it and the audacity is gone so that's
why I think people's environment just
suck but that's the challenge like if
you want to be stretched and you want to
grow then you have to push yourself you
have to go beyond what's comfortable for
you and do the painful thing take the
advice and take some action on it
because if you don't then you can't go
back and you're disrespecting your
mentor like they're not a mentor for you
if you're not following through and
actually taking action and listening to
them so you know step one is just go out
and show your passion and enthusiasm and
be remembered now here if you ready
knows you that's easy you don't have to
make that first impression step two is
then just ask for coffee have a set set
of criteria that you're looking for of a
problem that you want to solve asked for
coffee make a super low risk don't say
you want him to mentor you
just a small initial engagement and then
take action on the thing that he said to
do and then you can go back like if I
give it's the effort like if I give
advice to somebody and they don't take
it and they come back and ask another
question I don't want to answer i don't
want to spend time like i feel like i
wasted my time right if they're not able
to execute it like they tried order then
work quite well or you know the most
important part is not the result it's
not that you went out and achieved it
it's that you tried if you came back and
said I really tried I tried hard you
said post a video every day I posted 12
videos over 12 days and I still feel
like I'm not making it then then come
back let's talk about it because you're
putting in the work most people just
don't put in the work so that's what you
need to do to to show your mentor win
them over and and then that could become
a bigger relationship wow I did I heard
some new gold come out of that a answer
today and then our sourcing with good
information out yet new gold I aim to
provide new bulb change my time
interesting cool all right well I know
there's a little bit of a delay on my
end but where are you out with the game
your looks like you're 21 and 21 that
one is this 21 ah well we're 23 22 to 12
so our team is crushing I've done almost
nothing though my team is carrying me
hard I have zero kills zero deaths and
one assist so okay yeah but we're
winning so it's good a good thing
alright next question is coming from
Woodrow would joke and yeah Woodrow and
he
basically invented a board game and he
says the board game will change the
world it's very unique and easy to learn
but it takes a lifetime to master it
I've had a complete patent search
domestic and international my research
team final result is it's complete and
raised for fabrication I have a
prototype and it can be played from ages
eight to eighty eight at my age I'm
looking for a quick buy out if I need to
sign a disclosure form no problem I have
transparent blueprints and all
measurements all right Woodrow I'm not
sure excessively what your question is
but sounds like it's a really cool idea
board game could play from age 8 88 I'd
love to hear more about before game how
how it works but yeah looks like he
basically did everything on his end he's
ready to to put it out there and wants a
quick buyout do you have any quick tips
for for someone in that position emin
yeah i do wait idea me are you but
you're not going are you just deferring
to me on this I would well I'm not sure
what the question is and I'm wondering
is he trying to actually is he proposing
to you I'm trying to be proposing you it
as a potential buyer but I don't know
because I can't really see what the
specific question is so um okay cool
well my take on it is I think it's a
great idea yeah I think I think he's
trying to I think he's trying to this
guy 80 years old you know trying to sell
the game he's worked hard in this
concept and wants to watch somebody to
know capitalize on it marking it for him
you know buy him out he doesn't want to
do the work anymore he built it and just
want somebody to run with it at least
that's my understanding of the question
I'm just not sure being 80 years old but
she might be oh it's funny city became
my game yeah I think it's only cuz he
said the game is you can play it from
age 8 to 80 but what do you
something at my age he just say am I so
I'm assuming he's old I don't know how
oh ok ok ok I thought he was 80 ok well
whatever um listen it doesn't matter
anyway like it's not gonna happen mm-hmm
nobody wants to buy a concept of a board
game but that's the harsh truth you know
like you need to go out and you need to
get traction it's not enough yeah I
everybody wants to go buy a concept of a
board game you need to you need to get
some traction you need to you need to
you need to get momentum you need to
build it whether you're just doing it as
a you know Kickstarter campaign to build
some marketing up or whatever it is you
know nobody's going to say here Woodrow
is this check thank you for making this
amazing board game I'm going to take it
over and now selling like that is that
is not a fantastic strategy and the you
don't want to hear the answer like you
got to do the work to market it or find
somebody who can partner with you on it
looking for an opportunity but nobody's
gonna want to just buy a concept for
game mm-hmm like you know it's never say
never there might be some person in the
world but it's a it's a super like if
that's what you're basing your entire
strategy on it's super risky and so i'll
be looking at new i want to put in the
work to build this game out or not and
that's a as a it's a sucky position to
be in and it happens a lot of people not
not just board game people but people in
general who have ideas and realize they
don't have it they don't have the
capabilities to to monetize the idea and
then they get frustrated
it's building out the team to make sure
that you can like take it as far as you
can and build the team to help you get
there further but it's unlikely that big
companies going to want to just buy that
up especially with a like a board game
where there's no no problem there's no
media problem that like a company has to
solve through this new patented idea
that you have right so it's it's the
crappy yard sir of my work mm-hmm and
just start executing because he has all
this research and theory about how it's
gonna do but you at the end of the day
like you do have to just go out and see
how it does no well there's still work
to like I don't know he's built a
prototype but god I should go and test
it and see people want to buy it and you
can do it to a kickstarter campaign
where where you know you're trying it
out and you've seen two people like it
are people using it to people want to
pre-order at the people want to buy it
there's a lot you can do but you have to
be willing to do the work like it sounds
like he doesn't want to do the work you
supposed to sell it dad so until you get
your mindset around doing the work or
partner up with somebody who wants to
take an opportunity and do the work it's
not gonna it's not going to be it's not
going to be for you again to some fights
I just got two kills so I'm happy about
that I've contributed and we're on a
victory so far unless we do a big throw
here we're on our way to winning nice
try our six have not with you back today
right trainer six is not with us nope
just me and Jay rise jay is doing this
pantheon experiment let's see how he's
doing pantheon four kills and two deaths
so pantheon experiment is annoying that
decently so far
yeah oh alright next question is from
Jared and your ass I'm actually trying
to break a cycle from a 95 job to an
entrepreneur lifestyle and yeah he's an
artist but that's kind of it I guess he
wants some feedback about how to break
out of that nine to five job mentally
into the entrepreneur lifestyle so I
think my question that came to my mind
is kind of more deeper about you know
your why just making sure that your
lease at entrepreneur lifestyle I think
of people who who think that it super
cool to be an entrepreneur which it is
but like obviously entrepreneur ship
really its heart is coming out of a
place of having like a passion to bring
change or solve a problem or add value
in a specific way so just making sure
that your not wanting to pursue
entrepreneurship just because it's a
different lifestyle but what is the
value that you want to add through your
business once once you've kind of settle
that I think the cool thing about
entrepreneurship is that you can create
it to be what you want it to be even
your you know your schedule in the way
you think about everything is up to you
so you're already an artist which I'm
assuming means you already have that
ability to kind of think outside of
conventional boxes but yeah and then I
just say hang around with other
entrepreneurs see how they do it watch
Evans channel so much wisdom there
yeah um oh I'm taking get into a fight
we're going to get into a fight what's
happening here for me I love it I love
the intent obviously loving
entrepreneurs I feel like I want to
support what I would say is first you
have to start with what you're gonna do
right like I agree with Rishi on on why
you're doing it but figure what what
what's your idea everybody needs an idea
I you know where you going to sell you
said he was an artist that he say what
kind of artist no he just as an artist
and I'm not sure if his entrepreneur
goals will be artistic either hey Jade
okay isn't artist so what you gonna do
what's your big idea what's the problem
you're gonna solve right start there and
then find a way to start part time if
this does not have to be something that
you go all in on I'm not I hate giving
that advice I know some people do and
sometimes it's actually the best advice
for somebody but for me I I hate having
to go all in on something and and burn
the boats and I would not be the guy to
say quit your job and go through this
thing full time it just take the leap I
would be the guy who says start
part-time start in the evening start on
the weekends get your side hustle on see
if you can make this into something that
can support yourself when your dreams
and your goals that's that's where I
would come from and if you can make that
happen then you basically want to build
up to the point where you're making
enough money to do the quit your job I
think dedicating the time to make sure
that you're spending half an hour every
day is going to be the hard part a lot
of people can't find the time or maybe
maybe I'll say don't make the time like
you have busy lives you've got a lot of
stuff happening it's understandable but
you have to you have to find you have to
find a way to make the time for your
business
it's important every single day and then
in terms of the mindset that he was
asking about it's also now creating that
environment that helps support you on
your new path so if you know being
around entrepreneurs helps or watching
it for me it's the videos watching the
videos help every day put me in the
right mindset you know helps me think
bigger on accomplishing what my goals
are and doing that consistently helps me
helps me continue to win and so figuring
out what that is for you can make a
really really big difference all right
and we win I know where night yeah I
killed the base by myself okay I did
something I contributed so let's see
final stats I gotta pass I love it I I
finished three kills no deaths and for
sis jaraj was foul four kills three
deaths for sis so and then I'm working
out pretty clean pretty easy win pretty
exciting we're on a streak we are going
to stay out more on our great we'll see
we'll see how G rise like the new
experiment with the with the new
champion I'll ask him after how that web
see if it continues cool well I final
message Rishi fora for the audience um
final message yeah just keep keep being
willing to learn and if you want
mentorship you know be humble and let
them you know when they give you
something go out and do that and then
show that you actually respect that
mentors time yeah and and don't ask them
to be your mentor in the first
I feel like a lot of the answers came
down to just work mm so you want to get
a mentor okay we'll work on what the
advice is for the mentor and show that
you're put in the work are if you're
trying to sell an invention or a board
game the idea alone is not enough you
got to work that you build it into a
business if you want to start a business
but you're in the mindset of a
nine-to-fiver everyday working right
half an hour every day so I feel like
work is has been a consistent theme
today so so work work pour your heart
into it whatever you're doing make
something that you are going to be proud
of hmm so that's my message of the day
thank you guys for watching it's great
to be back Thank You Rishi for your
awesome co-hosts as usual Thank You Jay
rise for playing with me and all of you
all all y'all can I do that all y'all
yeah all y'all in the chat for for
cheering us on continue to believe or
whatever your one where it is I will see
you soon